Цим світом дедалі більше керують кліки
і дедалі менше - закони..
У цьому переконаний Олександр Варской.
Уже упродовж 20 років він - активний діяч російської хакерської сцени.
Його світ складається з даних, кодів та паролів.
Олександр - у постійному пошуку викриттів
та скандальної інформації.
Стосовно національності хакерів,
то її не існує. Це радше про субкультуру.
Тобто ви живете у своєму світі?
Я живу в ВАШОМУ світі.
У хакерській діяльності Олександр не вбачає
нічого протизаконного.
Усі дані - в відкритому доступі,
вони лежать зовсім не закриті, тому що інтернет так влаштований.
Як каша з каструлі витікає,
так само витікають дані. Вони просто довкола нас.
Олександр знає, що даними маніпулюють
і що Росія часто згадується в контексті кібератак.
Олександр стверджує, що сам особисто жодних замовлень
не отримував. Але каже, що накопати якусь підступну інформацію
про політика жодної проблеми
не становить.
Ну ось масиви даних, яких, власне кажучи, дуже багато.
Щоб знайти ваші, потрібно
відповідно дати команду на пошук.
Ось ця база, приміром, доступна
кожному для скачування. Бери - не хочу.
Тим часом німецькі спецслужби та кіберексперти -
насторожі. Вони не виключають атак на бази даних
та комп’ютерних вірусів саме тепер,
у період виборчої кампанії у ФРН.
Тим паче, що в минулому вже були прецеденти,
коли з комп’ютерів німецьких політиків викрадалися дані.
Ми бачили, як чинився, імовірно,
вплив на вибори в Америці,
спроба впливу на вибори у Франції. Все вказує на те,
що сліди ведуть в Росію.
Тому не можна виключати, і ми до цього готуємося,
що відповідні спроби чиняться
і з огляду на вибори в Німеччині.
Утім, атаки ведуться не лише на бази даних,
а й на громадську думку.
У цій споруді в Санкт-Петербурзі офіційно оселилася
Агенція досліджень інтернету.
Насправді за цією вивіскою стоїть центр онлайн-пропаганди Кремля -
так звана фабрика тролів.
Своїми коментарями вони маніпулюють онлайн-дискусії
і таким чином розпалюють конфлікти.
Журналістка Людмила Савчук таємно влаштувалася
тут на роботу, аби викрити схеми їхньої діяльності.
Гігантська кількість людей, які продукують в шаленому темпі
коментарі, пости,
картинки, відео.
Коли ти перебуваєш там в ролі працівника,
ти своє технічне завдання отримуєш просто на комп’ютер
і не знаєш, звідки воно прийшло і хто його написав.
Розписано, як саме слід подати тему, розставити акценти,
до яких висновків підвести читача.
Словом, там прописана твоя позиція
з того чи іншого питання
- твоя ПРОПЛАЧЕНА позиція.
Ідеться насамперед про роздмухування антиамериканських настроїв,
формування громадської думки щодо конфлікту на Сході України,
а також вплив
на російськомовну меншину в Європі.
Тролями працюють найчастіше молоді безробітні випускники вишів.
Люди, які працюють тролями, не мають жодних обмежень.
Тобто вони, прикрившись масками, фальшивими акаунтами,
можуть говорити все що завгодно.
Це екстремізм чистої води, розпалювання ненависті.
Тобто відповідальності в них немає жодної.
Фейкові новини, віруси чи викрадення даних -
сліди численних атак у мережі приводять кіберекспертів до Росії.
На тлі зростання кібернападів
Німеччина подбала про створення штабу
німецьких кібервійськ.
Але Олександр скептичний щодо їхньої ефективності.
Німецькі вибори? Сидіть спокійно,
у вас є суперзахисні програми.
Однак хакерів кремлівських спецслужб це не зупинить.
Вони ведуть боротьбу за російський вплив,
і не лише у світі кліків.